Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going
to explain a Russian sports comedy film
called “I Am Losing Weight”. Spoilers
ahead! Watch out and take care!
The movie begins in the city of Nizhny Novgorod,
Russia. Anya is a girl in her twenties living
with her bodybuilder and swimming coach boyfriend
Zhenya. She works in a bakery and hence is always
working with food. When the couple first met, she
was a size zero but over the months she has gained
a considerable amount of weight. One day, they
are called to a friend’s wedding. Anya tries on
clothes from a few months ago and realizes that
they do not fit anymore. She consoles herself
by saying that no one will notice but the change
in her body is significant. Zhenya knows this too
but he doesn’t want to comment on how much
weight she has gained, knowing that it is
a sensitive topic for her. After trying on a
few clothes and ripping some in the process,
Anya finds a decent one and gets ready.
When Zhenya gets a look at her in the dress,
his face drops in shock, she is no longer the girl
he was in a relationship with. He doesn’t want to
be seen with her at the wedding because all his
friends from the fitness industry will be there.
He gives her subtle hints, hoping that
she will stay home. To his relief,
Anya says that she wants to stay home and order
pizza. She urges him to stay with her but Zhenya
promises to congratulate the newlyweds and return
home in an instant. Before leaving, he picks her
up and puts her on the counter but dodges
when she tries to kiss him. Anya notices the
gesture but hides the fact that she is hurt.
After he leaves, she changes into comfortable
clothes and weighs herself to find out she
is seventy-six kilos. Although she is always
complaining about gaining weight, her only
resolution is to drink a glass of water after
saying her daily affirmations. Even now, she cooks
some fried food and scrolls through the internet
while waiting for her boyfriend. While she is on
the phone, she notices pictures of Zhenya and his
friends at the wedding. She zooms into a group
picture and is troubled to see that the girls
Zhenya hangs out with are skinny and fit. She
cannot help but compare herself to them. Then,
she comes across a picture of Zhenya and a girl.
On checking her profile she is horrified to see a
boomerang of the girl kissing him on the cheek.
The video is enough for Anya to get dressed,
put on some makeup, and rush to the wedding.
She calls her best friend Natasha to pick her up.
Natasha also notices that she has gained weight
but to her, Anya still looks just as beautiful.
She holds her face, telling her to be confident
about her body. When Anya reaches the venue,
she sees Zhenya dancing with the girl and getting
a bit too close. Jealousy makes the best of her
and she gets in between them. Zhenya is visibly
surprised but he continues dancing as the other
girl scoffs and walks away. A while later, the
couple takes a seat and Anya starts eating.
She asks him why he was dancing with a girl but
Zhenya tries to pass it off by saying they were
dancing in a group. When Anya pushes him, he
lashes out and admits that he doesn’t like her
anymore. He adds that she does nothing but eat and
has turned into a burden for him. Anya gets teary
but before they can talk, the newlywed couple
approaches them. They try to smile but it vanishes
when the bride asks Anya if she is pregnant.
Following that, Zhenya wishes her farewell and
walks away. In the next scene, Anya is on a bus
on her way to her mother’s house. She is crying
uncontrollably, not caring what people think fo
her. She walks into her mother talking to a date.
He notices something is off and walks outside to
give them privacy. Anya tells her mother that her
boyfriend broke up with her because of her weight.
Her mother comments that she is not fat, she just
has wide bones that she cannot control. The remark
makes her feel a lot worse than she already did.
At night, she sleeps on her mother’s couch while
going through Zhenya’s pictures on her phone.
She also comes across a picture of herself from
a few months ago. She zooms into her body and
is saddened to see how much she has changed.
The next morning, she gets a call from Natasha
who asks her to come over. Anya takes a bed on
Natasha’s balcony and stays there complaining
about the breakup. It turns out that Zhenya
had come there last evening to drop off all her
belongings. Natasha asks her to stay with her and
her husband Dimas for a few days until she finds
her own place. She tries to comfort her friend but
Anya doesn’t want to feel better, she only wants
to cry and complain about her lousy ex-boyfriend
who she wants to get back together with.
Even Dimas tries to make her feel better, claiming
that she is the sexiest girl in the town but it
does nothing to help Anya. She spends the night
on the balcony and is approached by Natasha the
next morning. Natasha tells her the story about a
friend who was in the same position as Anya. Her
boyfriend broke up with her over text because she
had gained weight. Instead of bitching and moaning
like Anya, the girl went to the gym and got slim
in only a month. The poor boyfriend regretted his
decision so much that he filled her office with
flowers to ask her to get back with him.
When Anya complains that she doesn’t have enough
money to join a gym, Natasha suggests she use the
one-week free trial in all gyms in the town and
do it for free. The next morning, Anya says her
morning affirmations, drinks a glass of water, and
goes to the gym for the first time in her life.
She takes a while to get accustomed to the
equipment and falls off the treadmill on
several occasions. But all her hard work goes
to waste because an hour later, she is at the
restaurant eating for two. Natasha, who works in
the restaurant throws her food away, disappointed
that she couldn’t commit for more than two hours.
She asks her friend to show some willpower.
On returning home, Anya applies
moisturizer all over her body
and wraps it with a plastic wrap. She hopes
that the trick will make her lose a few pounds
while devouring a bag of chips. At midnight,
she tries to steal food from the refrigerator
but is caught by Natasha. The next day, she
is determined to not eat anything unhealthy.
This is especially difficult for her because she
works in a bakery. While decorating a cake, she
accidentally licks icing off her fighters and does
ten squats to make up for it. Throughout the day,
food calls her name but she controls herself. At
one point, she is left alone with an entire cake.
She stares at it for several minutes trying
to make up an excuse to eat it. After pacing
around and almost breaking a shelf, she gives
up and devours half of the cake at once.
Anya realizes that she has a problem. She
looks for a self help group for people with a
compulsive eating disorder and joins a meeting.
Amidst the group of ladies is a single man
named Kolya. Anya introduces herself as Angela
and lies that she doesn’t have an eating disorder.
Instead, she claims to be a journalist who
is writing a story on eating disorders.
The group tries to reason with their condition,
not accepting the fact that they have a problem.
An infuriated Kolya points at each of them
and calls them fat, including himself. He also
says that it is obvious Anya lied about being a
journalist because she doesn’t want to accept she
has a problem. Anya pretends to get a phone call
and leaves the meeting but Kolya follows her.
He invites her to a nearby restaurant and Anya
goes only because she cannot say no to food.
Kolya proposes they become each other's fitness
sponsors. That way they have to exercise with
each other daily, ask each other before eating
anything and provide emotional support throughout
the process. Anya is unsure about Kolya’s true
intentions but she sees no harm in trying.
Starting the next day, they go to a park every
morning to run. At first, Anya is reluctant to be
with Kolya but as time passes, she realizes that
he is actually a nice person. He is not ashamed of
what his body looks like which is foreign to her.
Spending time with him makes her love her body as
well. They talk before every meal and are good at
helping each other since they are going through
the same problem. Soon, Anya starts to lose weight
little by little. Her confidence wavers when
she goes to pool parties and sees skinny girls
looking gorgeous. Whenever she feels frustrated,
Kolya helps her. They frequently scream on top of
their lungs to relieve stress. Anya wants nothing
but Zhenya’s validation which makes Kolya jealous.
In one and a half months, she drops down ten kilos
and is ready to meet Zhenya again.
She buys a swimsuit and pretends to bump into him
at a swimming pool. He works as an instructor and
is stunned to see her. After chatting for a while,
they get into the pool and start splashing
water at each other. Everything goes well
until the girl from the wedding arrives and
introduces herself as Zhenya’s girlfriend.
Anya is heartbroken for the second time. She
parties and drinks all night to forget about
him. The following morning, she wakes up naked in
Kolya’s bed. He assures her that he did not look
at her naked. A flashback from the other night
shows us that Anya was about to go home with a
stranger but Kolya arrived at the right time
and took a punch in the face to save her.
Following the strange morning, she goes to her
mother’s house and tells her everything. According
to her mother, Anya has unresolved trauma from
her father who left them when she was only a kid.
Hence, she wants Zhenya’s validation even though
he is not good to her. Anya understands what
she means and goes to meet her father the very
next day. She takes Kolya as her driver because
the drive is five hours long. On their way, Kolya
often tries to get closer to her, showing that he
likes her but Anya is oblivious to his advances.
They finally meet her father Sergey in a wooden
house where he lives with a woman. Anya asks him
why he didn’t want to be involved in her life.
Sergey, on the other hand, reminds her of the time
he came to her birthday with a present but she
flipped him off through the window. At night, Anya
accidentally drops a candle and lights the wooden
house on fire. Sergey yells at her for ruining
his house, not caring about her safety.
Anya and Kolya return home immediately
after. Before separating, she kisses him
on the nose. Kolya is on the top of the world
on his ride home. He even trades his watch to
buy flowers for her. Somewhere else, Zhenya
comes to meet Anya and apologizes to her.
They end up making love after talking for a
while. When Kolya returns with the flowers,
he sees them and walks away disappointed.
The next morning, Anya wakes up with Zhenya who
comments that she looks so much better than she
did a month ago. This makes Anya realize that she
doesn’t want an uncertain relationship where she
is always scared her partner will leave her. They
get into an argument yet again and Zhenya walks
away. That evening, she goes to Kolya’s house,
wanting to be with a friend. But Kolya
is so furious that he gives her an apple
and declares that their relationship as sponsors
has ended now that she has lost weight.
The next morning, she goes to Natasha’s house but
no one opens the door. She uses the neighbor’s
window and a pipeline to dangerously get inside
the house. It turns out that Natasha and her
husband had a huge argument after which he
left. The girls talk to each other and feel
a lot better. The next day, Sergey comes to meet
Anya again and apologizes for being a bad father.
He also dances with her like he used to do when
she was a kid. After the two reconcile, Anya goes
to a fitness marathon to meet Kolya. She finds
him drinking a cold drink and throws it away,
asserting her dominance as his sponsor. She also
declares that since he has not lost enough weight,
it is her responsibility to help him no matter
what. They take part in the marathon and
complete it with all their might. In the end,
Kolya gathers enough courage to kiss her.
For the first time in her life Anya
realizes that obsessing about her appearance
will not make her happy. True happiness
lies in accepting yourself as you are,
like Kolya did. He always worked hard to
improve his health but was never ashamed of his
appearance. Anya strives to be like him.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out. Thank You for watching.